the a45 is one of the busiest highways
in Germany it's an important north-south
connection and a transit route for
truckers it's also one of the highways
with the most bridges like the Lenna
Valley Bridge seen here more than 80,000
vehicles cross it each day far too many
the bridge which was built in the 1960s
is showing signs of wear and tear caused
mainly by heavy transport it's already
been closed to trucks weighing more than
40 tons
we have cracks in the underside of the
bridge which have now been filled in
though the bridge design was too narrow
the components are exposed to a lot of
dynamic strain and that causes new
cracks we have to constantly keep track
of it with this bridge to make sure the
new cracks get filled in quickly the
companies in the area are dependent on
the highway the ironworks in anta book
is having problems delivering to
customers because of the bridges weight
limit this iron pipe intended for a wind
turbine weighs some 30 tons it has to be
transported from north rhine-westphalia
to the harbour in Antwerp Belgium by a
special transporter and both together
are too heavy for the ailing bridge the
head of the manufacturer is furious we
have a transport that weighs about 60
tons in total including the vehicle and
we're not allowed to take it on the 8:45
that makes me very angry because then we
have longer shipping times that affects
the drivers rest breaks in some cases we
don't get to the port in time the number
of vehicles on Germany's highways has
tripled in the past ten years that has
consequences there are plans to replace
the Lenna Valley Bridge Construction is
scheduled to start in August other
bridges will be refurbished but there
isn't enough money to renovate the
entire a45 in our state highway
authority we're looking at as many as
800 bridges and more keep being added
that need to be rebuilt if we add them
all up we wouldn't need billions and we
don't have that much money right now we
have to arrange funding for the future
there are also plans to widen the road
from four and five lanes to a total of
six lanes but that will take years
despite the transport difficulties the
ironworks intends to keep its
manufacturing facilities here
it makes parts for gas and oil pipelines
as well as offshore wind parks more than
80 percent gets shipped abroad isn't
yeah we started here as a private
company to help contribute to the
economic security of the region and
create jobs we want to do what we can
we've invested millions but we're
hindered by the fact that we can't use
these roads it's some 250 kilometers to
Antwerp and the special transporter has
to take a big detour to get there these
kinds of deliveries won't be able to use
the a45 for another ten years
that's how long the reconstruction work
is expected to take